that's a nice it's just scripted right  okay  and try to speak as much as possible  oh we have two guests so you have the  opportunity and all kind of questions to  practice okay so before you get up cause  our Poochyena was the fit possible  so we make two kinds of pasta we're  going to make  Nayla pasta not inside water it has us  we could do that  no no no we're gonna make a foodie sauce  okay  and then we make or a check that yes  yeah somebody saying ears okay first I  say I said I got that left and then we  have it so oh yeah or wreck your yeah so  what what is usually nears recipe that's  traditional from this region from the  he'll Tennessee Valley and that region  is called cooler Wow  and you will eat chapter but  traditionally one of the recipes would  be roughly but we already made pasta  with properly so we will make or  objective Alyce Caron said it's with the  kuzuri  who's Sorella and mercy so some nice tan  so we can do something fresh